uh
good evening members and welcome
to cabinet meeting 17th of june 2021
fire alarm procedures if the firearm is
activated
vacate the offices via the stairs please
do not use the lifts
assembling holy square on the green
officers will assist you and advise when
it is deemed safe to return to the
chamber
please switch off or turn to silent your
mobile phones and do not make or receive
calls whilst the meeting is in progress
please note this meeting is being live
stream for members of the public
the meeting will also be recorded and
will subsequently broadcast on the
internet
does anyone intend to film the meeting
no
the following members have asked to
speak under council
procedure rule 20.1 item 4
councillor austin item 6
councillor bailey councillor ghana item
7
councillor everett does anyone else wish
to speak under 20.10
thank you council robin item six
are there any other members
are there any apologies for absence
no apologies for absence does anyone
have
any interest to declare in the items of
business on the agenda this evening
no of previous meeting
to approve the summary of
recommendations and decisions of the
cabinet
meeting held on the 29th of april 2021
copy is attached to the agenda pack
as this is the first ordinary meeting
for this camp cabinet i propose that
these
minutes are taken as read since they are
for the meeting that was held under a
different cabinet
do i have a secondary secular council
assumers
do members agree
item four evaluation of retention or
disposal options for
18 albert street ramsgate to introduce
councillor bayford
thank you chair 18 albert street is a
grade 2 listed building
it was previously occupied as a shared
ownership property with the council
owning a share
the previous occupants who earned the
remaining share were responsible
under the terms of the sharing
arrangement for the maintenance of the
building
the property is in very poor condition
as detailed in the report
with high estimated costs of
refurbishment
property is also poorly laid out with
accommodation over three floors
connected by a narrow unwinding
staircase
the kitchen and bathroom are extremely
small and there is no
outside energy space these reasons is
not considered suitable for retention as
part of the council's rented housing
stock
there is a specific requirement on the
council to ensure that any disposal of
vacant dwellings are at market value
it is therefore recommended that the
council test the market
by disposing of the property at auction
i move the recommendations in the report
thank you um councillor baker speakers
under 20.1
councillor austin thank you chair
um the i'm speaking on behalf of the
three central harbour councillors and
groups within the community who we've
talked to and we would like to propose
that this decision
be postponed for a period of at least
three months
we quite see the difficulty with this
property as
rental housing but we do think that in
view of its greater listed status
and the fact that it is so close to the
addington street area which for people
who aren't familiar with ramsgate is
effectively becoming
ramsgate's old town um it's an area that
is becoming increasingly popular it's an
area that has huge potential
for the development of cultural
facilities
and in the light of the landscape future
work that's going on in the consultation
that's happening in the community
we think there's a possibility that
something could be made of this building
uh as a cultural asset as a community
asset
as something that will generate income
for the council
and that funding may be able to be
brought in externally
to refurbish this potentially beautiful
building back to the state that it was
in
and uh um it could be a real
benefit to ramsgate as a tourist
attraction and as a community asset
uh we are concerned that if the property
is sold
we have a lot of negative experience in
ramsgate of land banking so we're very
concerned that the property
might just be left to rot and uh
we would ask therefore for a state of
execution on this building
ideally for six months but if uh cabinet
is not available to that then for three
months
while we discuss with the external
funding team
and um historic england whether this may
be
a possibility to do something with as a
community asset
thank you
thank you thank you council austin um
the disposal receipt could be used to
support the development of new
affordable homes in a more
cost effective way disposal will allow
potential new owner to refurbish the
building and bring it back into use with
the potential to restore the historic
shop front on the ground floor
so we will be happy to see any local
people at business
or businesses interested in bringing the
building back into use
having the opportunity to acquire the
building at auction
this process was also satisfy the
requirement of the council for disposal
to be at market value
um or perhaps you like to add something
to that
sorry uh thank you councillor
i think the one thing i would add to
that is that um
the any delay is likely to see further
deterioration in the building
um and i think that is potentially
problematic with
what you're suggesting
no
so councillor bayford would you like to
move
yes
our cabinet agreed on the
recommendations
item 5 representation on executive
appointed outside bodies
for 2122
to which i will introduce
the cabinet is being asked to agree the
list of the following nominated
nominations for the executive related
outside bodies as shown as annex one of
the reports
british ports association councillor
ashby british
resorts association agm conference and
executive meetings councillor pew
community safety partnership council cup
domestic violence forum councillor cup
and councillor joe bafford
east kent opportunities limited cancer
ashby
east kent special development company
councillor
robert bayford police and crime panel
councillor cup local government
association coastal special interest
group
councillor pugh lga district council
network
councillor ashby lga general assembly
councillor ashby
lga strategic aviation specialist
interest group councillor ashby
margate town partnership this item has
been
replaced by the margate town team which
does not have a member representation
therefore it has been removed from the
list
south east council england councils
council ashby
supporting people in kent commissioning
body council cup
phanet harbour user groups councillor
ashby and councillor pew
thank quality bus partnership councillor
linda wright
tourism south east councillor pew your
leisure
thank subgroup councillor ashby and
councillor hugh
do i have a seconder
cancel a cup thank you do members agree
thank you i move on now to item six
coastal lift current position
to introduce councillor bob bathord
yeah thank you chairman this update was
requested by the previous administration
to understand the issues regarding the
viking bay and ramsgate lists
following a review of the work required
it was agreed that the work to ensure
viking bay lift is operational for this
summer would be undertaken
that cost of 17 400 and that this is
allocated from the council's brexit fund
which is provided by government
the work is due to be completed at the
beginning of july
there has been a delay due to bespoke
new paths having to be made
on the completion of this work the list
will be operational
there will also be a new emergency
response and attendance procedure to
ensure that if there are any problems
then these can be fixed as soon as
possible including the release of
trapped passengers
the list is over 20 years old and to
bring it up to modern day standards
a further investment of 45 000 would be
required
this would basically replace all the
major components and whilst this would
give the list more longevity
no budget at the present time has been
allocated for this work roundscape lift
is more problematic
due to the theft of lead from the roof
48 thousand pounds of work has already
been undertaken
that it is anticipated that a further 20
000 will be required to get the lift
operational
however this will be subject to a
structural survey that has only just
been completed
to see if there is more structural
damage than first anticipated
therefore until we have a better
understanding of the condition and work
required
no further budget has been allocated ask
having it to
know the report chair
[Music]
thank you council bayford speakers under
20.1
councillor bailey
thank you
good evening everyone um first of all i
just want to
um say how pleased i am that the effort
is being made to get the viking bay lift
opened for this summer
for those who are dependent on using
this lift though it was very
disappointing to hear that the date for
the opening has been set back again
particularly as they were only showed a
fortnight ago that would be opening as
of next week
i appreciate the difficulties of having
to wait for parts to be sourced and
especially manufactured particularly in
these covered hit times
but when gulpers keep being moved it has
the effect of undermining trust and
confidence
i'm glad that improved measures
including a dedicated manager have been
put in place to manage the daily
operation of the lift
and i really hope that it will continue
to continue to be regularly maintained
and monitored out of season two
i would like to know um what insurance
can be given tonight that the lift will
in fact be ready to open on the revised
date
that is the beginning of july and i'd
also be very interested in knowing more
about the longer term options for
upgrading the lift to make it compliant
the report state stipulates that the
current repairs are only expected to see
us through this year
so what about next year and the ensuing
years thank you
okay yeah yeah thank you councillor
bailey
um i obviously agree with you totally
about the importance of the lift of the
residents of broadstairs
and it is very frustrating that
deadlines have been
uh missed but it's totally beyond the
control of this council i mean there's
no
pleasure in this council missing the
deadline and getting the inevitable fact
that comes its way
you know circumstances put us there as
far as going forward is concerned as i
said
in my little speech um there's a further
investment of 45 000 which will be
required to make this serviceable
and it's thought that that could
possibly be for up to five years but
we've got to look into that a little bit
further
but it is being reviewed at the moment
thank you to you move this uh
to oh
sorry i can't sit down you know too much
a hurry there that's the ghana
yeah yeah thank you
yeah thank you leader yeah yeah i echo a
lot of what um
councillor bailey has said and i might
echo it
in my little one spiel but as you're no
doubt aware especially
the three broadcasters based cabinet
members as councillor bailey said there
is disappointment in the town that
the promised opening of the lift has
been delayed
um and what i can understand the reasons
for that
but and dismayed that expectations
weren't managed properly in the first
place
the report states that the current
repairs will only ensure that the viking
bay lift is operational
for the remainder of the summer season
and leaves a question after this future
unanswered
i think the question needs to be
addressed urgently
a recent council website statement said
that a long-term strategy for both lifts
will be formulated to consider their
future as this report does not address
this
i have a couple of questions when will
this long-term strategy be considered
and agreed
and does the new administration agree
with me that fanuc beaches should be
accessible to all residents and visitors
and will they confirm that they will
work towards providing
and maintaining a permanent
all-year-round solution for all the
lifts
thank you
okay um i'll ask mr waiting to comment
on that but i mean
i think that uh again i've already said
that you know
we're disappointed as anybody that we've
missed the deadline
um can't keep saying that and the tdc
didn't want that to happen but it just
did
um and as far as managing expectations i
mean people were told what we thought
was the case and then as soon as
uh the different was known then the
people were informed
um i also have said that we're looking
right now at the future we're
considering this 45 000
pounds but it will be irresponsible of
me to say right now
on the hoof that we're going to make
that available because
it's not budgeted for that money would
have to be found
and all i can do is to assure you that
we are taking the business of the lift
seriously and we're looking at them
um i'm not sure when you say uh all
uh fanuc beaches to be totally
accessible to everybody i'm not sure
that's a promise that anybody could make
so i'm not prepared to make that one but
i don't know if mr wait you want to add
anything to it
uh yeah i'd just say that in terms of
uh operation uh 365 days a year
it might be a bit of an issue uh but
for us as officers is we're gaining all
the information we can in terms of what
works required the cost of that work for
both lifts
and obviously we present that to cabinet
and cabinet can then make that decision
but we are working on the on well in
terms of the replacement parts
you need to appreciate that the cost of
of uh some of the goods has
significantly increased and actually
the fact that they've had to make these
goods from scratch so they've actually
had to take the old ones out and
actually manufacture new ones
that's what's taking a bit of time so
hopefully and i'm still
pushing that the the lift will be open
in the first week of july and and
definitely by the start of school
holidays
thank you gavin um to speak under 21 one
council album
yeah thank you cheer um i'm not going to
go over what my
two colleagues behind me have uh have
said
um but what was on in regards to the
brawl says
um of course we're all sorry it's put
back
you know none of you know we would like
it to be open on the day that
it was said um
but i take what mr wasters said in
relation to bespoke
uh machinery parts that are required
and uh and and they're not easy but i
think what you
what residents got to take from from
that
is that uh hopefully the ball says this
will be open for the rest of the season
however the ramsgate lift is really what
i'm
concerned about um because one is a wall
councillor
and who's is shadowing uh councillor
bayford
um it is extremely disappointing uh
that is unlikely to be available for
2021.
um the residents around here are really
clear that
they it's it's a necessary
thing for for all people not just
disabled people for for families to be
able to use
prams get prams down et cetera et cetera
and what i'd like to ask
is um just for some clarification
um can i ask please if the the insurance
claim of the 48 000 in insurance claim
was that just for the repair of the roof
once was the lid was nicked uh was it
just for every
replacement of that and uh
if so can we not go back
to the insurance company uh
because obviously when the roof was off
the
the water damage that was uh the ingress
into the building itself and into the
machinery
um surely that now that's now we've had
a look at that
can we then find it that if uh that if
that is the case can we then go back and
reclaim
so the council can then get some money
for that
from the insurance company um
the other the other thing is within the
report it mentions
the the first floor doors um
that are that that need replacing
um you've just mentioned council paper
about any other
structural issues so i think that's
obviously very very important
that we get whether it is uh the actual
uh
not the internal workings of the lift
but the structure of the building itself
is damaged so i think that's very
important and that needs to be done as
soon as possible
so that we can that we can get that so
can i ask that that is done
as quickly as possible so that the
residents of ramsgate can then know
exactly what the issues are and and for
that to be put out
to them because that helps us as wall
counters to be able to do that
so just from those questions uh chair if
i could get an answer to those of you
please thank you
yeah councilman um i think mr white will
be the best place to answer those but i
think it's fairly clear that
at the moment it's a bit of an unknown
quantity um and at the moment i'm
blaming you
um so
yeah i mean in terms of the damage was
that the lead was taken off we had water
ingress and they fixed it so
i'll get the the detail of that to you
uh like i said is the dundee structural
survey
and they've done some work to see if we
can keep the actually get the lift
operation because the lift is working we
just got
we've just got issues particularly the
bottom where the the doors are
opening and once we get an indication of
what works required we'll obviously and
the estimate is 20
000 but i would say that that 20 000 is
not being allocated it's just a
an assumption based on what the the
liftec told us but we should have that
sort of early next week and i can
i can let you have details of that on
the town council as well
thank you yeah fine thank you for your
comments mrs we have julie noted
um would you like to move the proposal
the recommendations
um the cabinet is being asked to know
the report
just that asks cabinet to know the
report share
do i have a second dog
okay do members agree
item 7 margate digital leveling up
funded
to introduce councillor pugh
[Music]
thank you as identified by the leader
last week
we really do appreciate the opportunity
made available to us by central
government to be a priority one area
for the leader nut fund this report
highlights a second opportunity that it
has
to bid for the funding for margate
digital a cutting-edge
industry-relevant training space which
aims to influence creative thinking
and technology inspire people and
provide industry-ready
candidates the center aims to deliver
inward investment
raise aspirations provide opportunities
for retraining and support smes in the
centre
east kent college group proposes to
deliver more than 200 learners
in the first year he will be primarily
aged between 16
to 19.
the proposal aligns with the market town
deal which we heard about last week's
meeting
and will support the regeneration and
repurpose of margate high street
we are supportive of the bid and it says
the fall backing of the mp for the
family north sir rochelle
in fact we have been lucky enough to
have more than one opportunity to bid
to this fund with two mp constituency
areas in the district
i would like to recommend that one we
approve submission of 11 up bid
to the 18th of june 2021 deadline
two we delegate authority to the chief
executive
and the leader final sign off of the 11
up bid
and three the council will not make a
financial contribution in any form
within the 10 financial contribution
encouraging the prospectus
and this will be contributed by east
kent college group
thank you
thank you councillor pugh speaker under
20.1 councillor everett
thank you leader i'm sure you'll be
disappointed to say about this
um i want to say at the outset that i'm
fully supportive of the margate digital
project
all such investment in vanity is a good
thing and this is an exciting initiative
labour councillors represent the most
deprived areas of margay
and we want to see them regenerated with
more opportunities for local people
i do however have serious concerns about
this bid
it is simply not acceptable that the
cabinet paper was published 24 hours
before this meeting when the bid itself
has to be submitted on friday
that is the opposite of transparency not
just from the members perspective
but also from the public's it's not a
very good start for this administration
i do recognize of course the heavy
workload placed on the director of
regeneration
by the landscape leveling outbid indeed
that is one reason the labour
administration did not support the
second bid
because we knew there was no capacity to
deliver it properly
the report itself is substantially based
on the one the council received last
week for ramsgate
it's not at all clear what information
could have been outstanding to today's
publication
and that's why i've missed it it doesn't
even set out how much the bid is for
and i don't think council of pewter how
much it was for either
i think the council should be told that
in a formal setting
but of course this isn't really the
council's bid at all
it's very much a case of his master's
voice or perhaps in this case
her masters and if we haven't known that
it's made clear at 4.2
that this is a proposal from the mp
now i don't have any problem with sir
roger gail over there he's entitled to
lobby for his constituency that's his
job
but he is the council's job to balance
the risks and opportunities for the
whole district
not to take instructions from ymp or the
other
the mp is supposed to be consulted but
not to the exclusion of everybody else
this bid is a clear and obvious risk to
the ramsgate leveling outbid
and we know that because the director of
regeneration told cabin in her report
last week
that the funding overall was likely to
be oversubscribed and the best option
was to focus on one bit
cabinet clearly hasn't taken that advice
it won't wash i'm afraid to argue that
the competition between big spoon ramsey
and margay
is no different from the competition
between ramsey and dover or derby
or darlington we all know that once
margaret got a town deal
ramsgate was never going to get one
it would be beyond naive to think that
the conservative cabinet
is not creating a risk that the
government will say
thank you very much we'll take the
cheaper option for margate and that's
very done
whatever assurances they give this isn't
the government whose word is his bond
alternatively we might see some money
taken away from ramsey to give to the
margay bid
and that would be tragic because the
ramco bid is first
class this is an occasion when i hope
that i'm wrong i really do
because i want to see as much money
coming as possible
but if what i think happens does happen
it will be the thought of a conservative
cabinet
a conservative mp and a conservative
government
not the officers and not the council as
a whole
i will be angry about that but more
importantly ramsgate will be angry
and ramsgate will not forget thank you
thank you chair and thank you for your
questions and point
um it was funny as you were uh
giving your speech or your comments i
kind of had in my mind
the fact that we have a conservative
administration we have conservative mps
we have conservative government
but you laid out for me so thank you for
that i mean i think it goes without
saying that
all of the bids will be first class of
course we have fantastic officers that
work incredibly hard
and they continue to do so um to accuse
this cabinet and this administration of
not focusing its efforts i think it's a
bit disingenuous um
but at the same time i wouldn't expect
anything less um
i need to be honest there's probably
much else to say apart from that
although i know your concerns
i think that this is an opportunity that
we'd be mad uh to ignore
we'd be mad to turn down and i think
that actually is something that we
should put all of our support behind
but of course officers if they have
anything else to add
thank you councillor pugh councillor
both would you like to speak
yeah thank you chairman i mean i i can
understand um ramsgate being upset about
this in a way
but it's just another example of the
parochialism that over the years has
held
the whole thing back i mean we do need
to think
a bit more about planet as a whole
and this particular bid it's got margate
on it
but surely it's for the benefit of all
of our young people
the 16 and 19 year olds who desperately
need the future
and this is actually heading them the
right way
you know towards good well-paid jobs to
qualifications
and there won't just be market kids
doing that they'll be from all over the
place
including landscape and i thought it was
you know
the fact that in the landscape great
emphasis is put on how much the people
of ramsay want opportunities for their
young people
well here we are so this is sort of a
cooperative big in many respects rather
than
an opposing one i think and i think it
should be seen in that spirit
personally
thank you councillor baker um we have
examined this in great detail appreciate
that it was the
full report was late coming out but i
can assure
members that um this cabinet has spent
long hours last week and this week and
even at half past five
this afternoon examining this bid
and we also gave uh full
consideration to the landscape there was
a lot of work that went into that so
that we could get it in time
on the basis that we were only in
control for
i think five days so um
to say that we didn't we haven't
examined either
um especially with this bid i can assure
you that we have spent quite a lot of
hours on it
um i would like to pass over to the
chief executive
because she can confirm that
the question regarding whether the
impact
if the margate digital bid
would have an impact on introducing
the landscape bid was thoroughly
examined
and we have been assured by
who is the checkbook holder for these
bids
um that each an individual bid will be
considered under its own merit
and it and it is entitled every mp in
the country is entitled to put a bid in
so i'd just like to confirm this has
nothing to do with
uh his master's voice or his mysterious
voice this is
a very exciting project and i only wish
that when
i was um
looking at educating myself when i lived
in margate 30 years ago
that this type of opportunity was around
for me because
this is very exciting and i think the
youth um
will benefit greatly for the whole of
that this isn't just about marga
it's just the premises happens to be in
margay and it is an ideal
premises to actually launch this
fantastic and exciting project
so i'm equally excited for the
landscaping
and um obviously we'll be putting our
full
effort behind both bids and hopefully we
will be successful with both
but i'd like to pass you over to the
chief executive to
confirm that um that is the actual case
that one does not affect the other
[Music]
thank you leader um yes um
just to confirm that actually i think
it's very positive that actually
it is very obvious and quite right that
everybody's supportive of this project
um and i think you know at the end of
the day it is a very good bid along with
the ramsgate one
uh in respect of the concern that's
being raised around
whether one bid undermines the other bid
uh i can confirm that our understanding
is
uh and this is has been confirmed by uh
government representatives that you will
all be aware that every constituency
is entitled to submit up to one bid
we do have two constituencies two mps so
we are entitled
to submit two bids the information we've
also received is that has to be seen in
the context of those bids
are just competing nationally with all
bids that come forward
um and at the end of the day mhclg will
make that decision but
they those are the rules of submitting
we're entitled to submit to this
i would just like to tell you the
opportunity to confirm the amount of the
bid
that's been submitted for the margaret
digital leveling up
it is actually a bid for 6.3 million
pounds with match funding
thank um the louise rescue
for the work that she's put into this
and also for the margot digital team
that have also contributed considerably
to get this packed together
in a short space of time and the finance
team because they have been
having to scrutinize and check numbers
for for uh most of the day i think
um they've been working on it so so that
we can get it here tonight so that we
can get
approval so tomorrow we can move the bid
forward
and i really hope that both bids are
successful because it
is good to see money coming in from
central government into this area
so if you'd like to move
thank you yes i move the recommendations
can i have a second please
do members agree
thank you everybody that concludes the
business of tonight's meeting and i
declare the
meeting closed at 7
34